il a démissionné le 1er octobre dernier
jour des élections au québec le
commissaire de l'upac robert lafrenière
a bien quitte officiellement ses
fonctions aujourd'hui parce que cette
démission sera effective ce soir un
départ qui en a surpris plusieurs
et ce quelques années avant la fin de
son mandat jean parents le souhaitent
avec isabel richer bonjour isabelle
caroline on essaie toujours de
comprendre quelle est la raison la
goutte peut-être qui a fait déborder le
vase pour qu'ils quittent comme ça sans
donner d'explications ou effectivement
parce que il part en emportant tous ses
secrets et en emportant la vérité avec
lui la véritable raison pour laquelle il
part je serai bien bien en mal de vous
le de vous l'apprendre parce que on se
dit lui qui a tellement voulu être nommé
pour un deuxième mandat au mandat qu'il
a obtenu en 2016 pour cinq ans donc ça
allait jusqu'en 2021 et qui il a obtenu
sept nominations au terme d'une
manoeuvre qu'on lui un pur reprochés
rappelez-vous si je vous le rappelle
savall bien à limay l'upac avait arrêté
nathalie normandeau marc yvan côté et
plusieurs autres personnes le jour du
budget en 2016
est il bon ça va être un peu un coup
d'éclat mais c'était peu de temps avant
que l'on nomme la personne à la tête de
l'upac
donc il se plaçait dans une position
robert lafrenière où il était plus
possible de l'évincer parce que si on le
congédiait et qu'on le leur ne met pas à
la tête de l'upac
on se serait dit on va évidemment le
parti libéral est tellement fâché qu'il
est arrêté des libéraux étaient
sollicités se sont alors on se dit
maintenant qu'il était ruineux renommée
à la tête de l'upac louis pourquoi qui
est il maintenant alors que yéyé même
pas proche de la fin de son mandat alors
qu'il s'était garantit cette nomination
la et le faire témoigner
je sais pas si ça apporterait la vérité
à tout prix je ne sais pas s'il
viendrait expliquer pourquoi il parle
est-ce que la cohésion en venir à québec
pourrait vraiment avoir le pouvoir de le
faire dont on sait qu'ils ne veulent pas
le faire mais ce qu'il pourrait le
contraindre de venir témoigner
oui mais vous et moi on sait bien que
contrainte quelqu'un a témoigné on ne
peut pas s'assurer que ce sera la vérité
qui en sortira et c'est ça qu'on veut
savoir c'est pourquoi
tout ce qui nous a permis de faire c'est
de spéculer et l'option la plus probable
c'est que il n'accepte pas les échecs
mais pas seulement lui mais ranger bien
des gens n'acceptent pas les échecs de
l'upac et c'est un peu pour cette raison
qu'il laisse la tête
oui le climat de travail à l'intérieur
étaient pourris dénoncé il ya eu des
rapports là dessus mais c'est sûr qu'il
a eu des revers assez brutaux surtout en
fin de mandat notamment l' affaire guy
ouellette
évidemment tout le monde y pense alors
il lui packard était guy ouellette
on ne peut pas accuser pendant à peu
près un an et le gros revers qui lui pas
connu
c'est ça venait de la part du dpcp alors
le dpcp a dit le web et les mandats
d'arrestation de perquisition le mandat
de perquisition sont pas valides
alors on ne poursuit pas cette affaire
là c'est sûr que c'est une gifle et le
la question qui demeure caroline et je
veux pas m'embarquer dans une
spéculation à tous crins mais là la
sphère marc yvan côté marie maude denis
venait à la cour suprême mais vient
toujours à la construire le 12 décembre
c'est prévu le 12 décembre
cette semaine on a appris que le dpcp
demandé un report
c'est rare parce qu'ils sont rares les
dossiers qui se rendre en cour suprême
alors quand une date pour aller plaider
la cour suprême de principe était ravi
le dpcp dit ah on demande
on repart on a des nouvelles
informations
qu'est ce que ça nous dit à nous ça nous
dit oh mon dieu la dernière fois que le
dpcp à dix on a des nouvelles
informations
ç'a donné lieu à l'arrêt du processus
contre guy ouellette
alors là on est un peu inquiet qu'est ce
que le dpcp détient dans cette affaire
là qui pourrait faire trébucher la
sphère côté normandeau est ce que c'est
un autre est ce qu'on s'en va vers un
autre échec ou quelqu'un ce serait
vraiment très négatif pour l'image de
robert lafrenière
j'ai spéculent je n'en sais rien mais
y'a vraiment c'est ferran part de
mystère encore autour de tout ça
isabelle merci d'avoir été là vous allez
certainement par là votre émission de
salaire est possible voire moins